Here's the situation.
There are dark forces at play--
the deep state,
globalists, Bill Nye.
And this program
will oppose them at all costs.
But just like Lee Harvey Oswald,
I can't do it alone.
We...
We have...
we have an incredible team
of citizen journalists.
You may already know them
if you've been a loyal listener
to the Oppo Radio Network,
or watched our YouTube videos
or subscribed to our anti-
mainstream Snapchat stories.
And now they're all here,
covering the stories
you need to know about.
Starting with our resident
First Amendment champions
and social provocateurs,
Josh Sharp and Aaron Jackson.
And here they are.
They're over at Berkeley,
where Free Speech Week
was just cancelled.
Guys, what's going on?
Jordan, Free Speech Week
may have been cancelled,
but we are not going anywhere.
Because the Constitution
guarantees Americans
the right to free speech.
And it also guarantees
an audience for that speech.
Yeah, preferably on TV,
maybe radio,
we'd also take streaming.
Either way, this crinkly
ol' bitch lets us say whatever.
Yeah.
You don't have to agree with it,
but you do have to accept it.
-Also, follow us on social.
-Yes. -Right, right.
Keep fighting, guys.
-(cheering, applause)
-That's great.
There's so much to cover here.
As you... as you may know,
many NFL players
have been taking a knee during
our precious national anthem.
For an update, we have
citizen journalist Laura Grey
in her living room.
Laura.
Jordan, I feel attacked.
Is there anything more violent
than a nonviolent act
of civil disobedience?
Those knees
don't belong on the ground.
They belong out on the field,
smashing into groins and faces.
Yes.
Athletes are there
to get concussions,
-not to make us think.
-Exactly!
Progressives love
freedom of thought so much--
what about freedom from thought?
You know what... you know what,
if I wanted to spend
my whole Sunday thinking,
I'd watch baseball.
Yes.
God bless you, Laura.
Now, obviously,
The Opposition is a lot more
than just a half hour
of nightly television.
Over at Opposition Radio,
our resident expert Kobi Libii
is mid-show breaking down
current events. Let's listen in.
...which is what a pumpkin
technically is.
But to get back to the story,
The Washington Post is all over
what's causing these hurricanes.
Tons of coverage.
Two words you won't see
in any of their articles,
Maxine Waters.
Why not?
Let's back up and talk eugenics
for a second.
Yes. Okay, now... Yeah.
You don't hear that kind of talk
from "vetted sources."
Let's go to Niccole Thurman.
Niccole Thurman's at a Trump
rally waiting for it to start.
Niccole, why does
mainstream media insist
that all black people
support Democrats?
Ugh. Jordan,
I voted for Obama, okay?
He never did anything for me.
Obamacare was bull(bleep),
all right?
I get my health care
from the Affordable Care Act.
Yes.
-Now, Niccole...
-(cheering and applause)
personally, I bet you get
a lot more respect from Trump
-than Obama.
-Mm-hmm.
The second I walk
into any Trump rally,
it's like the room stops,
all right?
Like, I am basically
an instant celebrity. (chuckles)
And then Trump's staff
just brings me
right here behind the podium
every time.
I'll tell you what.
-I will tell you what...
-(cheering and applause)
Yes. All of my black friends
are so jealous
that they don't even talk to me
anymore.
But you know what?
I'm on the Trump train.
-Woo, woo.
-Yes. Woo, woo, indeed.
-Yeah. -Next, we go
to Tim Baltz in Alabama
watching tomorrow's
Republican Senate primary
between Luther Strange
and Roy Moore.
Who's looking good, Tim?
Neither one of 'em, Jordan.
We need a candidate
further to the right
than both of these guys.
Okay, uh, uh, Tim, they're
both pretty darn conservative.
Roy Moore has conflated
homosexuality with bestiality.
I can't get behind Moore
until he comes out
against true bestiality,
which is when animals have sex
with other animals.
Imagine it, Jordan, a dog having
relations with another dog.
Yeah. That's how dogs reproduce,
Tim.
-What are you, a Democrat?
-Okay, fine.
Keep us posted, team.
What a team.